what was it like for Jane to finally get
down in the bedroom can we have sex yes
I mean don't you so much this Monday
Jane's about to lose it trust me it's
not everything long I don't want to
spoil anything I just want to say that
like it is everything the fans have been
waiting for it was Eddie everything Jane
was waiting for it's gonna be funny and
mental and a roller coaster and awkward
and everything sex really is let's be
honest sex scenes are not as not as
comfortable as people think or not as
like intimate not as sexual as people
think
but with but with the person that I lose
it to you made me feel very comfortable
I love that Thursday show after the man
in real life just saying hey dad you're
not supposed to be here until 2:00 I am
not having sex for the first time in a
shed what was it like on set that day
just tell me a little something because
we had Eva it was perfect I just
witnessed a very cute moment between you
and Eva Longoria can we invite you but
in here it's a big deal this is a big
moment it's a big moon rentable no me
the big moment in the show working with
this lady as your boss what is that like
for the day she's focused prepared
driven funny loving like generous and so
smart so smart oh my god she got lots of
grab on to - I had the dream episode
because not only that big Mona but no
and then Haim is a really good friend of
mine but we have glorious Stefan Emilio
Stefan Deanna good at all damn good at
all
Judi ray is like everybody was in this
episode like dying outrageous she is I
just like telling people what to do